so what I want to do in this story is I
want to get into the specifics of the
new product launch and the new things
you're doing and the stuff that's coming
out right now in the machine learning
but I also want to tie it into a broader
story about Instagram and how you
decided to prioritize niceness and how
it became such a big thing for you and
how you reoriented the whole company so
I'm gonna ask you some questions about
the specific product and then some
bigger questions I'm down all right so
let's start at the beginning I know that
from the very beginning you cared a lot
about comments you cared a lot about
niceness and in fact you and your
co-founder Mike Krieger would go in
early on and delete comments yourself
yep tell me about that
yeah not only would we delete comments
but we did the unthinkable we actually
removed accounts that were being not so
nice to people so for example yeah well
I don't remember exactly whom but the
back story is my wife is one of the
nicest people you'll ever meet and that
bleeds over to me and I try to model it
so when we were starting the app we
watched this video about like basically
like how to start a company and it was
by this guy who started the law Katz
company or a meme and he basically said
to forum community you need to do
something and he called it prune the
trolls and Nicole would always joke with
me she's like hey listen when your
community is getting rough you got to
prune the trolls and that's something
she still says to me today to remind me
of the importance of community but also
how important it is to be nice so back
in the day we would go in and you know
if people were mistreating people would
just remove their accounts and I think
that's at an early tone for the
community to be nice and be welcoming
but what's interesting is that this is
2010 right yeah and 2010 is a moment
where a lot of people are talking about
free speech in the internet and
Twitter's role in the Iranian Revolution
so it was a moment where free speech was
actually valued on the Internet probably
even more than it is now
how did you end up being more in the
prune the trolls camp well there's a
age-old debate between free speech and
like what is the limit of free speech
and is it free speech to just be mean to
someone and I think if you look at the
history of the law run free speech etc
you'll find that generally there's
line we're like you don't want to cross
because you're starting to be aggressive
or if you mean or or racist and you get
to a point where you want to make sure
that in a closed community that's trying
to grow and thrive you make sure that
you actually optimize for overall free
speech so if I don't feel like I can be
myself if I don't feel like I can
express myself because if I do that I
will get attacked that's not a community
we want to create so we just decided to
be on the side of making sure that we
optimized for speech that was expressive
and felt like you had the freedom to be
yourself so one of the foundational
decisions at Instagram that helped make
it nicer than some of your peers was the
decision to not allow me sharing right
and to not allow something that I put
out there to be kind of appropriated by
someone else and sent out into the world
by someone else how was that decision
made and were there other foundational
design and product decisions that were
made because of niceness
well we debate we debate the reshare
thing a lot because obviously people
love the idea of reassuring content that
they find Instagram is full of awesome
stuff in fact one of the main ways
people communicate over Instagram direct
now is actually they share a content
that they find on Instagram so that's
been a debate over and over again but
really that decision is about keeping
your feed focused on the people you know
rather than the people you know finding
other stuff for you to see and I think
that is more of a testament of our focus
on authenticity and on the connections
you actually have then about anything
else
so after you went to VidCon you posted
an image on your Instagram feed of you
and a bunch of the celebrities I read
some of that comments of boomerang
there's a boomerang right which gets you
in a technical error I'm gonna read some
of the comments on at Kevin's post sure
these are the comments
suck suck suck me suck can you make
Instagram have Auto squirrel feature
that would be awesome and expand
Instagram as an app that could grow even
more meme lives matter you suck
you can delete memes but not cancer
patients I love meme lives matter all
memes matter suck MLM meme revolution
CUC min stop the meme genocide make
Instagram great again
meme lives matter meme lives matter meme
lives matter
gang melon gang I'm I'm not quite sure
of what all this means is this typical
it was typical but I'd encourage you to
go to my last post last Father's Day
that's all nice they're all about how
handsome your father is right
there are a lot of there a lot listen
he's taken my mom is wonderful but there
are a lot of really wonderful comments
there so why is this post from a year
ago full of and meme lives matter
and the most recent post is full of how
handsome Kevin Systrom status yeah well
that's a good question I would love to
be able to explain it but the first
thing I think is back then there were a
bunch of people where I think unhappy
about the way Instagram was managing
accounts and there are groups people
that like to get together and band up
and and bully people but it's a good
example of how someone can get bullied
right the good news is I run the company
I have a thick skin and I can deal with
it but imagine you're you know someone
who's trying to express yourself about
depression or anxiety or body image
issues and you get that does that make
you want to come back and post on the
platform and and if you're seeing that
does that make you want to be open about
those issues as well no so
a year ago I think we had much more of a
problem but the focus over that year on
both comment filtering so now you can go
in and enter your own words that
basically filter out comments that
include that word
we have spam filtering that actually
works really well so probably a bunch of
those would have been caught up in the
spam filter that we have because they
were repeated comments and also just a
general awareness of kind comments we
have this awesome campaign that we
started called hash tag kind comments I
don't know if you you know the late site
and the late night show where they read
off mean comments on another social
platform we started kind comments to
basically set a standard in the
community that it was better and cooler
to actually leave kind comments and now
there's this amazing meme that has
spread throughout Instagram about
leaving kind comments but you can see
the market difference between my the
post about Father's Day and that post a
year ago on
what technology can do to create a kind
or community and I think we're making
progress which is the important part
tell me about sort of steps 1 2 3 4 5
like how do you you don't automatically
decide to launch the 17 things you've
launched since then tell me about the
early conversations well the early
conversations were really about what
problem are we solving and we look to
the community for stories we talked to
community members we have a giant
community team here at Instagram which i
think is pretty unique for technology
companies that literally their job is to
interface with the community and get
feedback and highlight members who are
doing amazing things on the platform so
getting that type of feedback from the
community about what types of problems
they were experiencing in their comments
then led us to brainstorm about all the
different things we could build and what
we realized was there was this giant
wave of machine learning and artificial
intelligence and Facebook had developed
a thing that basically is called deep
text which basically went is in June of
right so it's right there yep so they
have this technology and we put two new
together and we said you know what I
think if we get a bunch of people to
look at comments and rate them good or
bad like you go on Pandora and you
listen to a song is it good or is it bad
get a bunch of people to do that that's
your training set and then what you do
is you basically feed it to the machine
learning system and you let it go
through 80% of it and then you hold out
20% of the other comments and then you
say ok machine go and rate these
comments for us based on the training
set and then we see how well it does and
we tweak it over time and now we're at a
point where basically this machine
learning can detect a bad comment or a
mean comment with almost amazing
accuracy basically a 1% false positive
rate so throughout that process of both
brainstorming looking at the technology
available and then training this filter
over time with real humans who are
deciding this stuff gathering feedback
from our community and gathering
feedback from our team about how it
works we were able to create something
we're really proud of so when you launch
it you make a very important decision
you want it to be aggressive in which
case it'll probably knock out some stuff
it shouldn't what you wanted to be a
little less aggressive in which case a
lot of bad stuff will get through yeah
this is the classic problem if you go
for accuracy you will miss class
if I a bunch of stuff that actually was
pretty good so you know if I'm just
you're my friend and I go onto your
photo and I'm just joking around with
you and giving you a hard time
Instagram should let that through
because you guys are we're friends and
you know I'm just giving you a hard time
and that's a funny banter back and forth
whereas if you don't know me and I come
on and I make fun of your photo that
feels very different understanding the
nuance between those two is super
important and the thing we don't want to
do is have any any instances where we
block something that shouldn't be
blocked now the reality is it's going to
happen
definitely the reality is it's going to
happen so the question is is that margin
of error error worth it for all the
really bad stuff that gets blocked and
that's a fine balance to figure out
that's something we're working on we
trained the filter basically to have a
1% false positive rate so that means 1%
of things that get marked as bad are
actually good and that was a top
priority for us because we're not here
to curb free speech we're not here to
curb fun conversations between friends
but we want to make sure we are largely
attacking the problem of bad comments on
instrument and so you go and every
comment that goes in gets sort of run
through an algorithm and the algorithm
gives it a score from 0 to 1 on whether
it's likely a comment that should be
filtered or a common that should not be
filtered right and then that score is
combined with the relationship of the
two people know the score actually is
influenced based on the relationship no
score is influenced by and Instagram I
believe if I have this correct has
something like a karma score for every
user where the number of times they've
been flagged or the number of critiques
made of them is added into something on
the backend and that goes into this too
so without getting into the magic sauce
this is like you're asking like you know
coca-cola to give up its recipe I'm
gonna tell you that there's a lot of
complicated stuff that goes into it but
basically it looks at the words it looks
at our relationship and it looks at a
bunch of other signals including account
age and account history that kind of
stuff and it combines all those signals
and then it spits out a score of zero to
one about how bad this comment is
is likely and then basically you've set
a threshold that optimizes for one
percent false positive rate when do you
decide it's ready to go
I think at a point where the accuracy
gets to a point that internally we're
happy with it so one of the things we do
here at Instagram is we do this thing
called dog fooding and not a lot of
people know this term but in the tech
industry it means you know eat your own
dog food so what we do is we take the
products and we always apply them to
ourselves before we go out to the
community and there are these amazing
groups at Instagram and I'd love to take
you through them unless they were but
they're actually all confidential but
its employees giving feedback about how
they feel about specific features and so
this is live on the phones of a bunch of
Instagram employees right now there are
always features that are not launched
that are live on Instagram employees
phones including things like this so
there's a critique of a lot of the
advances in machine learning that the
corpus on which it's based
has biases built into it so deep text
analyzed all Facebook comments are
analyzed some massive corpus of words
that people have typed into the internet
but when you analyze those you get
certain biases built into them so for
example I was reading a paper and
somebody had taken a massive corpus of
text and created a meat machine learning
algorithm to rank restaurants mm-hmm and
to look at the look at the comments that
people had given under restaurants and
then try to guess the quality of the
restaurants he went through and he ran
it is it interesting because all of the
Mexican restaurants were ranked badly
hmm so why is that
well it turns out as he dug deeper into
the algorithm it's because in the
massive corpus of text the word Mexican
is associated with illegal illegal
Mexican immigrant because that is used
so frequently and so there are lots of
slurs attached lured Mexican so the word
Mexican has negative connotations in the
machine learning based corpus which then
affects the restaurant rankings of
Mexican restaurants that sounds are
awful so how do you deal with that yeah
well good news is we're not in the
business of ranking restaurants but you
are ranking sentences based on this huge
corpus of texts that Facebook has
analyzed as part of deep text it's a
little bit more complicated than that
so all of our training actually comes
from Instagram comments so we have
hundreds of Raiders and it's actually
pretty interesting what we've done with
this set of raiders basically human
beings that sit there and by the way
human beings are not unbiased that's not
what I'm claiming but you have human
beings each of those raters is bilingual
so they speak two languages they have a
diverse perspective they're from all
over the world and they rank those
comments basically thumbs up or thumbs
down basically the Instagram corpus
right so you feed it the thumbs up
thumbs down based on an individual and
you might say but wait isn't a single
individual biased in some way which is
why we make sure every comment is
actually seen twice and given a rating
twice by at least two people on to make
sure that there isn't as there's as
minimal amount of bias in the system as
possible and then on top of that we also
gain feedback from not only our team but
also the community and then we're able
to tweet things on the margin to make
sure that things like that don't happen
I'm not claiming that it won't happen
that's of course a risk but the biggest
risk of all is doing nothing because
we're afraid of of these these things
happening and I think it's more
important that we are a aware of them
and be monitoring monitoring them
actively and see making sure that we
have a diverse group of Raiders that not
only speak two languages but are from
all over the world and represent
different perspectives to make sure we
have an unbiased classifier so let's
take a sentence like these hoes ain't
loyal which is a phrase that I believe a
previous study on Twitter had a lot of
trouble with your theory is that some
people say oh that's a lyric therefore
it's okay
some people won't know it we'll get
through but enough Raider is looking at
enough comments over time will allow
lyrics to get through and these hoes
ain't loyal
I can post that on your Instagram feed
if you post a picture which deserves
that comment well I think what I would
counter is if you post that sentence to
any person watching this not a single
one of them would say that's a
mean-spirited comment to any of us right
so I think that's pretty easy to get to
I think if there are more nuanced and
examples and I think that's the spirit
of your question which is that there are
gray areas the whole idea of machine
learning is that it's far better about
understanding those nuances then any
algorithm has in the past or any single
human being could and I think what we
have to do over time is figure out how
to get into that gray area and like
judge the performance of this algorithm
over time to see if it actually improves
things because by the way if it causes
trouble and it doesn't work we'll scrap
it and start over with something new but
the whole idea here is that we're trying
something and I think a lot of the fears
that you're bringing up are warranted
but this is exactly why it keeps most
companies from even trying in the first
place and so first you're gonna launch
this filtering bad comments and then the
second thing you're gonna do is the
elevation of positive comments tell me
about how that is gonna work and why
that's a priority the elevation of
positive comments is more about modeling
in the system we've seen a bunch of
times in the system where we have this
thing called the mimicry effect so if
you actually if you raise kind comments
you actually see more kind comments or
you see more people giving kind comments
it's not that we ever ran this test but
I'm sure if you raised a bunch of mean
comments you'd see more mean comments on
part of this is the piling on effect and
I think what we can do is by modeling
what great conversations are more people
will see Instagram as a place for that
and less for the bad stuff and it's it's
got this interesting psychological
effect that people want to fit in and
people want to do what they're seeing
and that thatx that means that people
are more positive over time and are you
at all worried that you're gonna turn
Instagram into the equivalent of an East
Coast liberal arts college I think those
of us who grew up on the East Coast
might take offense to that I'm not sure
what you mean exactly I mean a place
where there trigger warnings everywhere
where people feel like they can't have
certain opinions where people feel like
they can't say things where everything
where you put this Sheen over all your
conversations as though everything in
the world is rosy and that bad stuff
we're just gonna sweep it under the rug
now that would be bad
that's not something we want so I think
in the range of bad we're talking about
like the lower 5% like they're really
really bad stuff I don't think we're
trying to play
anywhere in the area of gray although I
realize you know there's no black or
white and we're gonna have to play at
some level but the idea here is to take
out I don't know the bottom 5% of nasty
stuff and I don't think anyone would
argue that that makes Instagram a rosy
place it just doesn't make it a hateful
place and you wouldn't want all the
comments on your you know on your VidCon
post it's a mix of sort of jokes and
nastiness and that beauty and useful
product feedback and you're getting rid
of the nasty stuff but wouldn't be
better if you raised like the best
product feed it back and then the funny
jokes to the top maybe and maybe that's
a problem we'll decide to solve at some
point but right now we're just focused
on making sure that people don't feel
hate you know and I think that's a valid
thing to go after and I'm excited to do
so the thing that interests me the most
is that it's like Instagram as a world
with seven hundred million people and
you're writing the constitution for the
world when you get up in the morning and
you think about that power that
responsibility how does it affect you
doing nothing felt like the worst option
in the world so starting to tackle it
means that we can improve the world we
can improve the lives of many young
people around the world that live on
social media I don't have kids yet I
will someday and I hope that kid boy or
girl grows up in a world where they feel
safe online where I as a parent feel
like they are safe online and you know
the the cheesy saying with you know
great power comes great responsibility
like we take on that responsibility and
we're gonna go after it but that doesn't
mean that not acting is the correct
option there are all sorts of issues
that come with acting you've highlighted
a number of them today but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't act it just means we
should be aware of them and we should be
monitoring them over time one of the
critiques is that Instagram particularly
for young people is very addictive and
in fact there's a critique being made by
Tristan Harris who was a classmate of
yours and a classmate of Mike's and a
student in the same class as Mike's and
he says that the design of Instagram
deliberately addictive for example when
you open it up I'm laughing just because
I think the idea that anyone inside here
tries to design
something that is maliciously addictive
it's just like so far-fetched on we try
to solve problems for people and if by
solving those problems for people they
like to use the product I think we've
done our job well this is not a casino
we are not trying to you know eat money
out of people in a malicious way the
idea of Instagram is that we create
something that allows them to connect
with their friends and their family and
their interests the positive experiences
and I think any criticism of building
that system is unfounded and so all of
this is aimed at making Instagram better
and it sounds like changes so far have
made Instagram better is any of it aimed
at making people better or is there any
chance that the changes that happen on
Instagram will seep into the real world
and maybe just a little bit
conversations in this country will be
more positive than they've been I sure
hope we can stem any negativity in the
world I'm not sure we would sign up for
that day one but I actually want to
challenge the initial premise which is
this is about making Instagram better I
actually think it's about making the
internet better I hope some day the
technology that we develop in the
training set we develop and the things
we learn we can pass on to startups we
can pass on to our peers and technology
and that we actually together build a
kinder safer more inclusive community
online will you open-source the software
you thought for this I'm not sure I'm
not sure I think it a lot of it comes
back to how good it performs and the
willingness of our partners to adopt it
but what if this fails what if actually
people kind of get turned off by
Instagram they say instagrams becoming
like Disneyland I don't want to be there
and they share less thing I love about
Silicon Valley is that we we bear hugged
failure like failure is failures what we
all start with we go through hopefully
we don't end on on the way to success I
mean Instagram wasn't Instagram
initially it was a failed startup before
I turned down a bunch of job offers that
would have been really awesome along the
way that was failure I've had numerous
product ideas at Instagram
that were total flaws are there were
total failures and that's okay we
bearhug it because when you fail at
least you're trying I think that's
actually what makes Silicon Valley
different from traditional business is
that our tolerance for failure here
is so much higher and that's why you see
bigger risks and also bigger payoffs
you